[Music]
these are horrible horrible enemies
enemies like we've never seen before but
we're ensuring that they never again
have a safe haven to launch attacks
against our country we are making plain
to these savage killers that there is no
dark corner beyond our reach no
sanctuary beyond our grasp and nowhere
to hide anywhere on this very large
earth president Trump earlier today at
the Pentagon remembering the 9/11 2001
terrorist attacks joining us now the man
that killed Osama bin Laden author of
the bestseller the operator former Navy
SEAL Fox News contributor Rob O'Neill
every time at this time of year Rob I
play on my radio show michael w smith
song and we interspersed all this audio
about from news reports and the towers
said the next towers hit the pentagon
field in pennsylvania towers crashing
down every time I hear it it just brings
me back like it's yesterday you had the
unique opportunity to kill the guy
responsible if ever do you ever reflect
on that first of all Sean thank you for
having me on the anniversary it's such a
special day and just like you I hear
those things it brings me right back and
it's it's surreal how fast time flies
and you ask me if I can ever I can close
my eyes anytime I want and see my team
going up the stairs to get Osama bin
Laden and I can remember the feeling of
what it's like to know we're facing
death ourselves but it's worth it for
the innocent people that died in the
towers and the first responders that
went there the people on flight 93 and
Pennsylvanian and the people in the
Pentagon and it's again you know I was
just down there today at the 9/11
memorial is it's it's always incredible
to go that I like to go there a lot more
than just on the memorial because it
makes me realize what's really important
it makes it like President Trump said in
his speech today that we realized when
major catastrophes like that like the
terrorist attacks or even the Hurricanes
now we realize how small our differences
really are and that once were united as
a country we can we can defeat anything
and
made that pretty sure I love the fact
that he's taking it to them any serious
did you read about bin Laden's son and I
think United saw some of his kids do you
in particular remember him do you know
remember if he was there that day that
he is gonna now unite all these
terrorists no his youngest his younger
son Hamza was not there his his you know
his older brother Khalid was there and
he said the same nonsense and we ran
into him and took care of him quickly
and that's the same faith that Tom is
gonna reach we got men and women looking
for him right now it's gonna be a bad
day for him when we do find him
supposedly he's gonna unite it but that
I mean that's if that's what they have
as a kid it's because we're routing Isis
now we've hit al Qaeda really really
hard this is what they have it's the
same ideology that Isis has that al
Qaeda has that Al Shabaab has the
Khorasan group any of those savages in
North Africa that are uniting under this
uh yeah
the radicalized version of Islam you
know they're scraping for something he's
gonna raid a rattle a saber but he's not
gonna do much mm-hmm all right Rob
thanks you did a great service along
with all the members of SEAL Team six
none of you knew if you were coming back
great heroism and all the people that
fought in Afghanistan and Iraq many that
lost their lives and those that came
back with the most severe injuries thank
you for being with us thank you Shauna